hey guys it's Inka so I'm actually in
Shanghai for a few days and I decided to
make a quick trip to Hangzhou because
apparently the fanciest KFC is right
here called ke Pro it is a healthier and
fancier version of our neighborhood
friendly KFC so I am super excited to
check it out and see what it's all about
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're gonna start here let's order a
salad to start things off pasta salad
should I go with the mango there's a lot
oh is it so hard this one I think has a
crawfish we should probably go with that
in here we have assorted vegetables we
have dragon fruit we have avocado we
have corn that looks really good that's
still a sandwich this looks so good
chicken in here there's crawfish there's
mayo we have to go with this you can't
come to camp C and not have chicken
let's order this truffle flavored
chicken way you want to do fancy you
gotta have truffle oh there's so many
things the juice is all fresh oh wait
there is freshly squeezed
dragon fruit juice and to finish it off
there is a durian
crepe cake is that too much this is what
we have and now we wait
[Music]
all the food is here it's been serve
just now I look like I'm about to do a
profile video I'm really excited this is
a huge amount of food I'm actually going
to try the freshly squeezed dragon fruit
juice first I'm a huge juice fan dragon
fruit is really popular here in Asia
honestly KFC in like the last place I
would expect to find it that natural
sweetness very refreshing this is
honestly something I would expect to
find
elack juice generation or pressed juice
tree I don't even think there's added
sugar in here straight up just dragon
fruit it says tasty French Brittany
sounds about right
do we have the truffle chicken wings
this is what it looks like it looks
really good smells really good this is
actually tough for me
oh I taste the truffle now that fit on
top really was shallots and onions and
then I think they drizzle truffle oil
so you get that slight taste of trouble
actually have a good camp see in a long
time and the chicken is tender this is
really good and you don't pay if I
finish this the next thing is this it is
in this huge platter
this is wild can you believe you get all
these different ingredients of akkad oh
there's corn pecking foods chicken
crawfish and then there's egg proper
silverware at a fast food restaurant not
something you normally see let's try to
grab a bite that has everything
is a huge bite but the flavor is good
when there's so much variety in here and
the ingredients are fresh that is
something that I wasn't coming in
expecting also this portion size is
gigantic this is not just for one person
I love this little flag on top the
little capo time this is what the panini
looks like
[Music]
the chickens and then you have what I
believe is often Charlie it's the number
one a recommended item here it looks
like something that you would find at a
bakery that's specially ordered no
especially you know unexpected you do
actually see chunks of crayfish this is
what did it's not too much bread it's
not too much meat it's melted a and I
want to eat more
durian crepe cake
[Music]
you really do get that really pungent
smell of darien and you can see the
layers
that's real very and philly for people
who don't know what Darien is durian is
a Southeast Asian crew it has a lot of
thorns on the outside but on the inside
it's soft and pillowy is one of my
favorite fruits the only thing about it
is that has this really pungent smell
that a lot of people don't like I love
cream cakes
I loved your 'i'm down a try it what is
whipped cream and durian puree is super
creamy to find it here at a fast food
chain and to do it well that's really
really impressive my breath is probably
gonna stink for a long time i think that
concludes my time here at a throw i
really love what KFC has done here
they're really trying to make their menu
healthier for everyone if you get a
chance to visit henjo this is definitely
one of those places you should stop by
[Music]